[Music]
thank you for joining us America
Jonathan is in Nashville hi Jonathan
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thank you for taking my call how are you
better than I deserve
what's up through a fortunate set of
events I have received a what would be
considered to me a small windfall and
wanted to know how you would you would
best use that it's about $15,000
wonderful and I am a full season season
ticket holder for the Nashville
Predators and with their success my life
and I decided to sell a lot of tickets
including to the Conference Finals and
just realized that be the smarter thing
to sit home and have have money than to
actually go and so as a result we are
just curious on what to do with that we
have a couple of options and wanted to
see what you thought we were in the
middle of baby step two we have about
seventy thousand dollars in debt most of
which is student loans we actually paid
off our credit card earlier this month
and have the little card cutting
ceremony so it was great option two we
just had a baby four months ago and have
been renting for three years and would
like to buy a house we obviously have
nothing saved up for a down payment so
that could be an option or option three
we use part of it and reinvest in season
tickets for next year the way it works
is in an installment plan so if a if
it's a thousand dollars it's like 10
installments of $100 no interest
anything like that so so we could do
that and still have nine thousand left
over yeah what is your household income
it was 70 thousand it's gone down to
about 60 on the reason for the drop is
my wife is an in-school therapist and
elected to stay at home with our child
during the summer so for two months we
will not have that income okay let's go
back to the first two options
that one's easy turf on the first two
options allow wherever you are on the
baby steps and we want you to be
debt-free and have an emergency fund
before you buy okay okay so that leads
us to your debt snowball okay
just to continue to work your debt
snowball with any money that you can get
your hands on from any source okay full
disclosure I am a rabid Nashville
Predators fan and I'm a rabid hockey fan
I grew up playing hockey so I have to
completely come clean as a matter of
fact exec Bennett is running the board
today because Jim James is off and he's
in here producing the show and he's a
big hockey fan and he was just telling
me they were not going to Stanley Cup
because they're trying to pay off their
house and I'm just shaking my head and
he goes well you taught me that
so I got it I got it I got to say my
heart is hurting I'm just I got to say
it out loud
I feel like game six ticket yeah I
watched I watched it every minute of it
you know last night I don't have tickets
and so I did manage to scarf some from a
friend for Game four so but you're going
to see Game six you think uh not just
the price is there I mean I want to do
it smart for my family I give as much as
it hurts yeah well I okay let's uh now
before all of this happened before the
Stanley Cup happened and were you going
to renew your season tickets short
answer is no okay um and the main reason
is because you we just couldn't justify
okay child care yeah
forty years L in town 40 games a year
yeah and it's just a lot of it's a lot
to do
yeah right and I had season tickets for
years years and years and years I'm back
behind the goal right behind the Vince
Gill and I were sitting together okay
and so that's where I was and so you
know exactly where I am
he's had those tickets since day one he
and Amy have but um the unbelievable so
uh what would I do if I were in your
shoes you're really working very hard to
be responsible and I want to do anything
except trash my predators
in this answer okay because I don't want
to but you had already made the decision
to not renew your season tickets based
on your situation yes sir okay and you
use the word invest they're not an
investment and this year they turned out
to be an investment you've made big
money okay but most years it's a
consumption right it's it's a con it's
something you consume and you had made
the decision you weren't going to
consume that next year so I would
probably stick with that decision not
because of the Predators nothing against
them but because of where you are in
life you have decided you need to clean
up your debts and get you a house for
your baby okay before you buy
professional tickets season
ticket-holder you know and you can go
back and get tickets later there'll be a
time again that you can go again
okay now so I would as it hurts my heart
to say it but I would say I probably
would not renew because and I'm doing
that based on where you are and based on
that was already your decision okay and
I'm sticking with that that's that's how
I'm coming to that conclusion you follow
me is there okay
so that leaves us with taking the
windfall and throwing it at your debts
which gets you much closer to your being
debt-free which gets you much closer to
buying a house which is all grown up
good stuff and it's smart things to do
and you and I both know you can pick up
tickets depending on how the seasons
going throughout the season for a little
nothing if you watch what you're doing
even if the seasons going well you know
if now Stanley Cup tickets are different
so now having said all of that I would
tell you that I would be dishonest if I
didn't say if you are holding that
ticket and you have the opportunity to
go to a Stanley Cup game in your life in
your city with your team and you miss it
that would be a shame you should take
one set of tickets and go to the game
I still have game six well they gotta
get to Game six they gotta get the
likelihood statistically is there's
going to be a Game six but they got to
get there you know the possibilities
they don't make it
you you're holding that and you say okay
God if you want me to go you get them
became sick so because God's always
involved in sports we know that but yeah
I would yeah I would use those I
wouldn't quote be responsible on that I
wouldn't I think you should enjoy that
insight you know it's the world series
is in your town in your baseball team
you know mm-hmm that's just you don't
want to miss that at least one now do
you have to have all all you know when
they playing in Nashville three times is
that right potentially here potentially
up to three game six would be this it
would be the other one okay
yes so a games would be the third one
hit there now three and four and six
okay yeah I thought so and so yeah full
disclosure I'll be there Monday I can't
make Saturday but I'm coming Monday so
but uh yeah man that's aggressive
interesting discussion man it's kind of
fun so yeah it is talk how long have you
had those season tickets four years four
years pretty sweet yeah I had them item
for about ten years and I think we gave
him up two years ago we had
forward/center ice and I had my two
behind the goal and we gave him to our
team every year our team here not not
the program given to people who work to
remedy solutions and we gave them up at
precisely the wrong time which is why
they're winning I gave up my tight and
sweet to some Titans are probably going
to Super Bowl soon but anyway that's a
fun discussion man you're I tell you
you're doing good I'm not sure I would
have been able to even get through the
phone call without crying oh so I'm
going to get you towards your goals
where do you want to be when you're 40
where do you want to be when you're 50
what will be the smart move for you and
your baby and your wife and that's the
decisions you're making and go to game
six
it's humbly deal and maybe you get to
watch us clinch it in Game six how's
that our game six the Western Conference
Finals it was amazing yeah yeah really
these games have been amazing they've
been something else this town is on fire
man if they're and we're all proud of
our predators and so this is nothing to
discuss to trash the Predators but
that's hilarious though because I mean
literally the last commercial break Zach
and I are talking about this because
that's a huge fan
because prints cup and they're drinking
out of it right now so there you go
though predators 37 minutes last night
without a shot on goal we won that
everywhere but on the scoreboard so
we'll see we'll see Pittsburgh bring it
we'll see that start trash-talking now
hit oh my gosh what a great call this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]